we turn now to Colorado where your
President Joe Biden made a rare
appearance as uh usual as per usual
didn't go well in fact the trip started
with a very concerning moment during a
photo op with workers at a Wind Tower
Factory Biden randomly started talking
about the nuclear codes okay watch this
now look my my Marine carries that it
has a code to blow up the world that
doesn't this is not new weapons is it
all right
okay okay Joe Biden was not coherent
pretty much all day Dazed and Confused
even when reading the giant sized font
on his teleprompter take a look for
yourself but but I am friends with your
leader Mr Moon you know home you know
we're we're good guys here in Colorado
the wind turbine manufacturing
Vis is is investing $40 million to
expand his Factory and hire an
additional $1,000 employees solar
manufacturer B Meer Berger is building a
new solar cell Factory just down the
road in Colorado Springs instead of
cutting them like Congressman Trump and
bber want to do we could use it to help
Millionaires and millions of families
afford instead of millionaires millions
of families
afford little help with senior
care can someone interpret that for me
Congressman Trump uh what was Biden
actually trying to say how on Earth is
HE capable of being president this is
the toughest job in the world and he
wants to serve another 5 years uh has he
lost his mind uh I think it's becoming
quite transparent yes Biden is a
cognitive wreck I know it you know it
Democrats know it and but barring some
major trip and fall or emergency health
condition it looks like Joe is on a path
to be the nominee for the Democratic
party so given Biden's condition well
that means his vice president president
plays an important role unfortunately
his vice president happens to be kamla
Harris who polls lower than him and
today she couldn't come up with a simple
answer to a pretty simple question about
Tik Tok take a look you don't have a
specific view on on Tik Tok itself I'm
not commenting on that are you on Tik
toac yourself I am not do you are you
not like a people in my family are I'll
tell you that and you tell them to get
off you know you can tell young people
in your family all kinds of things to
do well we got the giggles but we didn't
talk about Vin diagrams as she calls
them whatever they are hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else